on frôle des records près de 800
personnes se sont déplacées aujourd'hui
au centre des impôts d'orléans ouest
depuis ce matin 6 guichet en libre
service sont affectés aux passes le
prélèvement de l'impôt à la source
car les contribuables ont du mal à s'y
retrouver
j'étais déjà venu aux modeuses au moins
de juillet et l'administration m'avait
demandé de revenir à cette période pour
pouvoir informer de ma situation
actuelle entre ce qu'on voit sur
internet ce qu'on dit à la télé bon
quand on est une personne d un point en
face de soi ça c'est encore autre chose
donc non c'est pas clair qu'en fait il
faut que j'assure internet sur
impots.gouv.fr montaut pour l'adapter à
la nouvelle situation de cette année et
si j'ai des questions a dit de revenir
après pour essayer de voilà le con ptd
compléter les réponses les agents des
impôts ont été formées pour répondre aux
demandes de modifications sur internet
ou directement au guichet on ignorait si
les gens le ferait tout de suite ou
attendre et attendre est effectivement
les gens s'en sont souvenus parce que là
on a beaucoup de monde qui viennent pour
des changements de situation donc c'est
des mariages c'est des naissances
essentiellement parce que ça aura un
impact direct sur leur taux
effectivement pour faire face à ce que
les responsables du centre des impôts
qualifie de révolution du personnel est
prévue en renfort au moins jusqu'à la
fin du mois